good afternoon and welcome to the John F
Kennedy jr. forum I'm Maggie Williams
director of the Institute of Politics
here at Harvard is my pleasure to
introduce tonight's moderator J Newton
small J is a correspondent for Time
magazine she's been on assignment for
time and Iran Iraq Jordan the UAE
Ethiopia Haiti Indonesia Australia
Canada and Europe closer to home she
covered the 2008 presidential campaign
traveling with in presidential
candidates Hillary Clinton and Barack
Obama Newton's small have covered the
White House Congress and the 2012
Republican presidential campaign before
joining time she was a reporter for
Bloomberg News it is our good fortune to
have J Newton's small as a fellow at the
Institute of Politics where in addition
to managing a very busy schedule she is
writing a book which has as its working
title broad influence it is my honor to
introduce J noon small to be here with
my old friend Reggie love who I was just
chatting with Reggie I think I wrote the
first profile of you ever in print in
2004 Christmas yeah it was the Time
magazine in 2007 you were so nervous
about it they're like don't write
anything mean about me I said I said
that I didn't want to take away and I
was like this campaign is not about me
this is about you know Brock Obama and
the message but I think Robert Gibbs
his point was it will make him look more
it will humanize the candidate that way
that was told you that's that's how I
sold it sounds like wise Jay keep
bothering me about this
there's writing this article well and I
started it all because now you have an
amazing book that's just come out so let
me introduce Reggie before we before we
started all the banter Reggie love is
you were a basketball and a football
star er I played I was on the team
he was a star he was totally a star and
and and and after graduating from Duke
you were going to go to New York you're
kind of on your way up to New York and
and he's decided you'd stop in
Washington DC and in turn you know for
this summer and this in this office of
this new kind of senator from Illinois
named Barack Obama and and that
internship ended up lasting a little bit
longer than you thought
yeah well so and to be totally honest I
was I was playing football
after college I was playing I spent you
every month you were semi-pro Packers
that's been a year with the Cowboys and
you know my mom had suggested that I
take a an accounting course my last year
of college and so when I'm in Dallas I
have I come up with this calculation of
like how many snaps I would have to play
and never in order to never have to work
again and when I finally calculated the
number I was like there's no way I'm
ever gonna make that many snaps so I
should look for a different career I
love that so he starts looking for
different career he decides I'm gonna go
you know in the finder let's make money
right so you only really like up to like
Goldman or something anyway well this is
kind of and I don't know how many
remember this was like sort of the the
Golden Age of you know I banking then
which you know it's 2005-2006 and you
know I had had classmates were making
just as much in there like annual
bonuses as I was making like in a whole
year
playing football and I was like and
they're gonna make that for 30 years
yeah well maybe not for 30 but you know
they made it for awhile so you're
looking at a lot of money you know money
signs going up to New York you thinking
I'm gonna make it bake a lot of money
for you know and then you stopped in
Washington and an intern for Barack
Obama which does not let's face it pay
well yeah they pay at all so I was I was
a staff assistant and I don't know who
how many people here have worked in a
in a members office on the hill is too
so and there's someone in the back so in
in in a congressional office you've got
like the member of Congress you've got
like a chief of staff and a senior
adviser and director of scheduling the
legislative director legislative
correspondent locations director and
then there's like staff assistant and
then there's intern yeah and so I was a
staff assistant and and I think when I
started I've made
I mean maybe $28,000 a year and I and I
lived in DC which is even I don't know
how that even worked out I don't really
I don't think I was actually and I must
have been in the red and you know I got
there and things were what I noticed was
that there was something special about
what was going on there and I would go
and Lauren Kidwell probably remembers
this was here is that Senator Obama
would have these town halls every
Thursday he and Dick Durbin would have a
town hall and people from Illinois would
come and visit and the the line that he
would always say that stuck with me was
that you know I would rather do what's
right for the American people than worry
about being reelected you know it was
like if if I do the right thing and I
don't get reelected but I'm fine with
that and I thought that that was just
like a very it was a it was a concept
that I kind of thought never happened in
politics and I thought when I was you
know when I was in college I study
political science I wrote papers on how
you know the correlation between dollars
raised and who wins a presidential
election or a senatorial election and it
was just so it was a refreshing point of
view and so as a staff assist and a lot
of people say well how did you get your
how did you go from staff assistant to
you know personal aide for the president
and it's like a you know it's a long
journey and to be totally honest you
know when people see Barack Obama today
they're like oh my god 44th President
Air Force One
you know he's got there's all these
things in the nuclear football but you
know in 2006 you know I would imagine
not many people what you guys if you
guys are from Boston you probably did
know who Barack Obama was because he
gave that speech it sounded poly I mean
like I remember covering that speech
when I was here in 2004 for the
convention and I bumped into then seven
state senator Obama doing a walkthrough
with Robert Gibbs he's we keep
mentioning he was the spokesman for for
the senator and then became
communication with spokesman for the
White House spokesman when Obama won and
it was like 7:00 in the morning we're
doing a walk here in the convention
center and Obama was like hey J cuz we'd
met each other within the Kerry campaign
and he was like let's have breakfast
I'll give you a preview of my speech and
and I was like okay cool and so he gives
me his preview of his speech and I filed
the story
it's like exclusive to Bloomberg's
previous speech and my editor was like
this is so Pollyanna and like hokey what
is this red America blue America United
States America never published it he's
like he's like you know you know this
guy huh like a but I said it's amazing
to me that you cuz you could it's he
does sound pollyannish right like when
you hear him speak and he sounded like
back then even in 2006 2005 but but
people responded right you saw people
respond well it's uh for me it kind of
reminded me of sort of growing up in my
church it reminded me of my pastor and
Charlotte a small Baptist Church you
know and goes up you know great cadence
great great delivery tons of passion and
you know and I don't know how many of
you guys go to church often but it
always seems like the message that he's
sort of the message that he's speaking
it's like directed right at you it's
like you need to participate you need to
go out and vote either educate your
friends you need to like take part in
what is a larger conversation that a lot
of people aren't participating in and so
no it it's definitely it was definitely
different you know
very different approach so you get
inspired and you decided $28,000 a year
is worth it living in the red is worth
it you're gonna stay you're gonna
sacrifice the job at Goldman right and I
and I and I told until Pete Rouse has
kind of been my Sherpa for for all
intents and purposes
he's a former senior adviser to well he
was chief of staff to Tom Daschle when
Tom Daschle was the Senate Majority
Leader he was a senior vice chief of
staff to Barack Obama in his Senate
office he was a senior adviser on the
campaign he was a chief of staff in the
White House I remember telling Pete I
said you know look I may not want to
stay very long I said maybe I'll stay
two or three months and I've been in DC
for almost a decade and and really to be
totally honest the first major challenge
that I had wasn't a challenge at all I
remember the day Pete calls me and three
other staff assistants into the
senator's office and it's like this
amazing room you know it's big couch big
desk eight by 10 photo of Thurgood
Marshall Muhammad Ali's boxing gloves
and a you know and I'm on a stand that
are autographed a photo with him and
Nelson it was a photo of him and Nelson
Mandela and you're sitting in this room
you're like man this is like this is
where like it happens this is it so it's
me and three other staff assistants and
Pete Rouse and you know you think you're
about to like write a piece of
legislation and he goes look I got a
problem and we're all kind of looking at
each other and he goes you know we have
a problem in the mailroom and we all
kind of look at each other and were like
mailroom like what kind of what possible
problem could there be in the mailroom
nothing interesting goes onto the
mailroom and you know I kind of you know
I look at everyone I volunteer and I
kind of raised my hand I'm like I'm
happy to help you with this problem and
so the problem was very simple so he
gave that sent State Senator Barack
Obama gave a great speech here in ball
in 2004 and people started writing him
at the United States Senate before he
was ever sworn in so there was this
whole pile of unanswered unresponded to
mail of almost six months that needed to
be sort of processed and so I came up
with just like a very systematic way of
like using you know a service that sort
of scanned documents but the
sergeant-at-arms an FTP site and PDF
I mean Adobe PDF and Excel and sort of
came with a process sort of digitized
our mail system so that we could you
know process it a little faster or
manage it a little better and to help
get rid of this backlog and Pete and it
takes probably you know two and a half
months or three months and you know a
couple interns and Pete thinks that I
can he thinks I can like walk on water
he's like you turn water into wine this
is like the most amazing thing ever and
I said well no it's really you know it's
really this FTP side and this you know
in Excel and an Adobe that did and I
just sort of put it together and from
that day forward Pete kind of felt like
there wasn't a problem that I couldn't
solve so you know if it was you know
anything from database management to
setting up the Bluetooth in his car you
know anything that had a battery
he felt like you know if you put Reggie
on it he'll he'll solve it so you stay
and then obviously history starts to
sort of unravel in front of your eyes or
surpassed before your eyes were senator
Obama then runs for president surprising
were you surprised I was surprising
really why I I just was I never thought
that I would have been working for a guy
who was running for president and it was
you know he hadn't been in the Senate
for you know even for a third of his
term so it seemed it you know was it was
surprised to me okay and I and I was I
wasn't very certain that he was gonna be
able to get his wife to sign up for it
either
no no any thoughts that Michelle
Michelle Obama she's
she's like the most beautiful stylish
person that I know and I don't get you
in trouble right well I think it was
funny the president said it on Saturday
night at the correspondent center he
goes he goes how is it that you know
I've lost most of the dark hair on my
head and Michelle still looks great
untouched smart thing for him is a so
you go you decide to go over to the
campaign with him was that a tough
choice or did you yeah that was actually
a funny story and so and so I was 23 at
the time I didn't never worked on a
presidential campaign I had worked like
on a small statewide race when I was a
sophomore in college and you know
everyone's like I want to be
communications director I want to be
state director and I oh I want to be
leader dance and all of a sudden one day
Pete brings me into the office and it
goes so what do you want to do in the
campaign and I you know and I and this
is where I think probably the smartest
thing that I said though at the time
made me look really stupid I said you
know look I don't really know what I
would be good at so why don't you make a
suggestion to me and I'll go out and
I'll try to do it to the best of my
ability and if I'm you know and if I'm
awful at it don't fire me just move me
someplace else
and his suggestion was he said you
should go on the road and you should
handle stuff and be like the body guy
and I had no idea what a body guy was or
what that meant and to be totally honest
had I known at the time I probably would
have taken it because if you would have
told me that I was gonna travel like 30
days a month and spend 115 days in Iowa
and 89 in New Hampshire and 70 into that
even though that it was kind of fun
I would you know it's it isn't
necessarily the most appealing thing
when you look at it in in these little
pieces right you know now I guess you
couldn't ended up in some worse places
where we can you could have been in
Chicago and a lot of people spent time
in DC but the travel is hard the travel
definitely was not it was not easy
so tell us and I'm gonna put so Reggie
meanwhile by the way is an amazing
photographer and and sort of chronicled
all of his travels with the president
throughout the campaign and and you
should pick up his book because it's
great and it has a lot of these
photographs so we're gonna start this is
on the campaign I'm one of the little
planes that they used to fly around in
Oh No
so this is early on and I always think
about I think this is really a funny
picture because you know I think he flew
we flew on that plane from like New York
to California like no bathroom in it
like you literally had to stop and
refuel in Kansas and in uh in Kansas on
the way to California that's like how
sort of low-budget at the beginning and
a lot of people kind of always think
they were like oh man you and the
president you guys have this great
relationship you must be from Chicago
you must be from the south side or your
parents must be friends or must be
boosters or donors and you know to be
totally honest I didn't know him and I
didn't know him from Adam when I came to
work for him and to be totally honest
today that I when I became like his
personal aide I think for probably the
first two months of it I think he felt
like I was more of a nuisance than I was
a value-add and I remember a couple of
times when you know we're in these like
really tight quarters and you know I'm
kind of I'm getting phone calls from
everyone he's supposed to be on the
phone call right now or he's supposed to
be in a meeting or these five people are
waiting where is he at he's late he's
not on time and so I'm kind of nudging
him along like sir you got to go XYZ
person is already there and they've been
waiting for 30 minutes and one day he
come he turns to me he says to me look
Reggie you were closer to my daughter's
age than you are mine I'm the person
running for president here you are my
assistant and he goes you're gonna have
to chill out
and so a lot of a lot of the job for me
was really learning how to you know you
know be a nuisance but not be a nuisance
so for those of you don't know what a
body man is let's let's describe a
little bit see you you you you stand
next to him in events and you have a
sharpie and ready all the time and you
and you received when he gets things
from people you get those things and you
have to sort of deal with them basically
everything that he doesn't want to do
you basically do blackberry you hold his
iPhone yeah so it's like it's like
everything from his wallet to his
personal device to you know briefing
books to making sure that his luggage
gets from hotel at a card a plane to car
to hotel room making sure that he eats
you know three meals a day if someone
you know a cousin or a friend or
whomever wants to see him in Cleveland
you know you make sure that they're
positioned or in the clutch or sitting
in the audience in the right place and
he knows where they are you knows who
they are and you know you just you're
kind of you take in all the extra stuff
so President Obama wins it becomes
President Obama and hanging out with
Marvin well I this is actually this
photos a really good photo mainly
because you know I think the story I
always tell behind this is if you look
at this photo you would say well there's
the guy who's the president there's a
guy I don't know who that's Marvin in
the middle and the thing that's really
funny about it is that we're in a tent
yeah we're in a tent that has no chairs
in the middle of a field in the middle
of nowhere in Virginia it's basically I
don't know it's probably 10 days before
before the election in 2008 and I think
with you guys at that point and I think
the thing that's really important is
that you know while you're doing
whatever it is you guys go off
or what you're currently doing like the
people you're with and the people you're
spending your time with like you gotta
have a little bit of fun even if you're
doing something that doesn't seem that
interesting or you're in a place that
seems kind of obscure or you're doing
something that seems sort of redundant
or repetitive you know it's always good
to be able to enjoy the people that
you're with and have a laugh because it
makes the journey a little bit more
bearable little easier when did the
president discover your basketball
skills I mean I played a Duke
I'm sure watch me play on TV or sit on
the bench when did you guys first when
did you guys first start playing yeah so
one of the so Matt Matt Rodriguez who
was our state director in New Hampshire
had a great idea he said look what we'll
do is we will have the prep we'll have
the candidate play basketball with local
firefighters and police officers in
their morning games and he'll get to
earn their respect and ultimately
they'll vote for them which is kind of
ironic cuz we didn't win New Hampshire
and so what they would what they decided
to do you can also make the day a little
bit longer because your first public
event really can't start before 8:30 or
9:00 because no one will really be there
so they would schedule a basketball game
with local people in New Hampshire at
like 6:30 so we get up at 6:00 go to the
gym play for an hour get shower and go
and so we were playing with some folks
from the New Hampshire staff and I know
look I was like 23 the time we were like
we were killing these guys it was like
you know we were up 20 points and
there's one play where you know I'm like
in my help side defense I like make a
deflection I run the ball down and I
like go up and I like dunk the ball and
I like run back down the court and he
kind of looks at me he goes look you
know Reggie it's like we want to win but
we want their support
I still think the president questions my
jump shot and my shot selection I
remember when the Duke basketball team
so I played a Duke & Duke wins a
national championship in 2010 so the
Blue Devils come down Coach K in the
Oval Office Barack Obama in the Oval
Office I'm kind of giving them their
briefing about all right you're gonna
turn left and you're gonna turn right
and the remarks from the podium and how
the sequins gonna be in and the
president kind of interrupts and he goes
so you know sometimes we're playing he's
saying Santa's - Coach K sometimes when
we're playing you know Reggie will just
take the craziest shot and then coach K
kind of responds back he goes no no
Reggie does not shoot on my team that's
your problem so I I think that you know
look at my game is I never no one ever
paid me to play basketball I love the
game love the play but I will say that
was the thing that actually did build
the bond and friendship between the
president and I I can remember the first
night you know it's a long day and we
were having a back-and-forth about the
NBA Playoffs kind of like this time it's
like kind of this time of the year and
Chris Paul is playing for the New
Orleans Hornets at the time and and Tony
Parker was still in San Antonio knee and
I said look like and I'm saying to him I
said Chris Paul is the best point guard
in the NBA I think it was no Chris
Paul's not that good and I said no look
like I played against him in college
he's fast with the ball he's shoots
great he's just a great all-around
player best partner in the NBA and you
know I look at my email one night it's
about 12:30 and it's like Barack Obama
I'm like like this is like this is gonna
be like bad like he's either something
something's missing or like something's
wrong he doesn't have something so I
open it up and it's like Tony Parker
stat line
and you know and I reply back with Chris
Paul stat line and I go you know pretty
pretty good but I still think CP is
better and that was like our first like
non-work-related communication where we
were just like not talking about
scheduling or talking points or
logistics or why he was doing something
that he didn't think that he needed to
be doing so I was always surprised when
I watched him play basketball during the
campaign what a trash talker he is I
mean he really talks trash and like
eel-like Hayes everybody on the team
like is it just these hyper competitive
I think he's a guy the ax talking trash
to him when he plays basketball
have you seen ax Rod play he definitely
is a trash talker and I have a there's a
great story in a book that I write and
it's it's still one of the funniest days
of my life we played a game in Iowa and
we flew to the walk we flew to Wisconsin
later in the day and the president or
the candidate is about to go on stage
and he's standing offstage he's being
introduced by Swimming's who's a local
person who's sort of talking about why
she's supporting the candidate and I say
to he's standing there holding the
basket want to say so sir you know
that's a girl's basketball and he goes
yeah I know it's a girl's basketball and
he throws it down the hall to Marvin
that's tall guy stand in there Marvin's
like six eight
Marvin's his trip director just to give
you like he throws the ball tomorrow and
he says to Marvin he goes he goes amen
maybe this will help you with your game
and Marvin you know he's like it's like
he goes look and I'll take he says I'll
take trash-talking from Reggie but I
won't take trash-talking from you sir
and he goes on and on and he says to the
president he says to the candidate he
goes well you know at least I didn't get
my shot blocked by 14-year old
the candidate goes he was 15 and it was
a nephew Avery and the candidates about
to like go back at Marvin and then the
curtains like open the music comes on
they're like and the next president
United States Barack Obama and in the
middle of this like he did trash talking
moment he's like announced the stage and
he comes off stage and he goes and he
says some he goes the whole time I was
given that speech I was really fired up
so we've redefined fired up and ready to
go he may have used another word I don't
know so so you decide you love it so
much you're gonna go to the White House
with the president and and you're gonna
keep doing it no I didn't think I was
gonna go to the White House at all
no no man the campaign was so long it
was 2 years 23 months actually and I had
taken that literally two months after
there are two weeks after the election I
took the LSAT
the the Tuesday before Thanksgiving so I
like was gonna go I was like gonna go
take the spring off go to law school and
that was gonna be it and we are and
shortly after the election Inouye he's
going to DC to meet President Bush mr.
president-elect meeting present
president-elect Obama
meeting president-elect Bush in DC and
on the flight over we're just we're
shooting we're talking we're just
talking sports and the my good friend
Chris Duhon had gotten a new contract
with the New York Knicks and and he had
a good game and he goes it comes over to
me I was on the plane he goes man he
said man Chris had a great game last
night he I guess he I guess he really is
worth all that money I should probably
take back all those main things I said
about him and he kind of says to me so
you're coming with me on this journey
you're coming with me on this right
talking about the White House and you
know and I'd already prepared myself and
that's gonna it's like it's not gonna go
like I never really wanted to work in
government like my dad works Social
Security but it's like like I really
want to work for the man like that
didn't sound cool
and before I can even before I even
realized what happens I can say yeah
sure I'll come for two years and I'm
like look I'm like who said that
and so I guess that's what happens
leader of the free world asked you to
come you go and it was I stayed for
three years and it was probably the best
experiences and the best life lessons
that I've ever learned and I think Jays
scrolling through some of these photos
and this is you know I I would tell a
different story about this but this is a
very great set up here this is the Rose
Garden no this is Bill signing signing
and you're in the back and I'm like
going out to check everything before I
put the remarks on the podium and so if
anything was ever wrong at any of these
events he would never go to like the
press person or the grounds crew he
would always say Reggie why wasn't this
right and so I the thing that I always
learned was that the right answer was
always yes sir
and I'll do we'll get that right next
time because debate him don't debate him
and and it's really easy to say to blame
somebody else because usually there's no
scenario that just involves like one
person like especially when you're in
these organizations there's there are
hundreds and hundreds of people who are
doing important jobs and sometimes I get
it right and sometimes they don't but
ultimately in my position my position
was basically to take responsibility for
anything that seemed to go wrong
which happened a fair amount yeah good
thing you weren't there when Obamacare
happen no I wasn't there you were there
yeah when did you leave so you how long
I thought you stayed 2011 oh my god I
meant when it went inflammation the
website
yeah the website exactly exactly so
would you have a story about this one
yeah so this is actually a very
interesting story here so this was the
first state visit and it was preparation
for it and its really a lot of work I
mean we fought for almost a month we had
meetings and walkthroughs and all
different sort of a bit preparation yeah
protocol and to be totally honest we I
think we did an amazing job except one
thing you know the headline for the
event was you know party crashers crash
and it was really an unfortunate thing
because everyone did an amazing job
a lot of work went into it 99 percent
executed without a flaw and the one
thing that goes wrong actually ends up
being the thing that is actually still
covered today and gets covered in India
and so no so and I think the the main
story behind it is that like you know
there's a lot of work and a lot of
preparation that goes into into not only
not only for him but all the people who
work for him him being the president and
I think the main takeaway for you guys
it should be that there will be a lot of
moments where you're gonna do a lot of
things and put in a lot of time and
you're not going to get the outcome that
you hope to have and even when you don't
get the outcome that you hope for you
still have to put in the time and put in
the effort to continue to go on so now
you you've left in 2011 I know you went
to Wharton
and you're talking over to the South
basketballs not as good there and you
and you're doing environmental
consulting right like I work for a
financial holding company called
transatlantic and we're buying medium
sized companies that supply equipment
and services to utility companies and
only gas companies but you remain
friends you know he was lucky enough to
invite me - that was USA vs. Brazil it
was a it was a preseason it was a
exhibition game at the Verizon Center
and it was funny because he went back to
talk to Coach K and the team before the
game and the next time I saw Coach cases
he says if he wasn't the president
there's no way he would come in to talk
to my team and halftime especially they
were like it was like a tie game but I
think this is a great photo and I was
lucky enough to - for him to even invite
me to go with and I think you know you
have to enjoy you know the things that
you do and he definitely I think the
funniest part about that is I got like
10 emails from people who work in Nike
being like why is he wearing all this
Under Armour gear a national television
he should be wearing Nikes so I'm gonna
open up to questions in a minute and
just so you guys know that you lined up
the microphones which are around up here
to ask questions and need to keep it to
at least two minutes for a question and
you're - identify yourself please and
your question must end with a question
mark I would do the rules of Harvard let
me talk when you kick off the question
answer session with a question that was
planted by David Axelrod um when I saw
him last week and and I said you know
actually gonna be interviewing Reggie
for the forum what should I ask Reggie
and accent to ask you about a story
involving Hillary Clinton so and I kind
of remember this but we differed on our
recollection I remember this being at
the Sioux City Airport and Iowa he
remembers that being in the New York
City Airport but it was after so
story is Billy Shaheen who is Jeanne
shaheen's husband at some point said
something incredibly insulting the
president he he sort of hinted that the
president might have dealt drugs in when
he was at Columbia University
he immediately apologized you know
resigned from the campaign the Clinton
campaign condemned his remarks and and
Hillary said that the next time she saw
Barack Obama wherever it was she would
personally apologize and so there on the
time it was it Sioux City or was it New
York do you think it was in DC we were
both wrong okay so both acts and I'm
just remember this yeah and so so you're
in an axe is there you know in both
staffs are kind of in the terminal and
there so they're seeing the candidates
meet on the tarmac but the only people
who could actually hear what the
candidate said to each other were Huma
who was Hillary's body person and Reggie
and so axe said to ask you because a
parent we the legend goes that things
got incredibly heated it looked like
they were screaming at each other so
that's like yeah so acid to ask you to
put you on the spot and say what exactly
it was said that day hey look I think I
think the so we're in DC a in Washington
DC in to Jays point there was you know
some comments that were made about the
press about the candidate at the time
that were a little unsavory and so he
had he addressed it to her and she kind
of said look I had no idea and that he
was going to do that and I'm really
sorry about it and and in you know and I
think for the most part I think you know
at that point in time I think maybe
someone felt that the apology wasn't
sincere enough and look and I think this
is your brand and these comments that
are made you know have a huge impact and
you know like your kids like read this
stuff and you know your wife reads of
stuff and so I think you know it's one
thing to differ on you know your policy
in Iraq
another thing too you know have sort of
these sort of liable things being said
about you and how does she take the
request for an apology more of an
apology
yeah you know she wasn't too thrilled
with it she got it's definitely very
animated to say the least you know it
was kind of awkward because you know I
don't know if you guys have ever been
around like your parents are fighting
and they you're there but you probably
shouldn't be there but they were already
kind of at it and you're just like maybe
I shouldn't really be paying attention
so you're kind of trying to act like
you're not like yeah so man I was like
man that was a great event at the
convention center huh serious should we
break this up no I I'm Ben Bulger and
I'd have a question about dealing with
challenging experiences with the
president for example I think once you
might have misplaced his briefcase
temporarily miss morning if you could
kind of get was a good story like that
and like you know how did you you know
everyone's human how did you resolve a
setback that you had with the president
didn't work out
look I mean I like start sweating
thinking about that day and so that's a
great question Ben and so when I tell
the story sort of my first really big
mistake was the day before the South
Carolina debate which was the one of the
first debates in the primary I leave his
bag it's left in the car in Florida and
I don't realize it until we're like
speeding down the tarmac to take off so
I won I call everyone I can I'm emailing
people hey here's a bad can how can we
get it to South Carolina can we FedEx it
can someone drive it like is anyone
flying like what are all the options out
there and then there so so part one is
just like trying to like solve the
problem right
now the real solution of the problem
would have been to not have left the bag
there at all and so then the other part
of it is when we land he he says hey you
know Reggie where's my where's my bag
and I'm like thinking to myself well ok
I think the bag will be to the hotel
tonight before we get there I think I'm
not a hundred you know you know
something had happened the plane get
delayed or something like I can tell
them the truth and say you know look I
love your bag in Miami or I can say ya
know it it's in the other car I grabbed
when we get to the hotel tonight and I
went with a version of something in
between which is like you know it's in
route what do you mean it's in route I
said well it's in route to the hotel
from Florida and he goes why is it not
with me here and I go whoa you know we
got left in the car and we've solved it
it's gonna be there and later that day
we're in the campaign headquarters and
in Colombia and he kind of asked one of
the staff members for a room he goes
Reggie come in and talk to you sits me
down and he kind of says look you know I
you know you have one job to do and if
you're not up for doing your job then
it's gonna make it really hard for me to
do my job and I'm sure there are a lot
of other people out there that would
love to have that job that you have and
so you know I you know I go think of
myself so yes sir
like you know this is a terrible mistake
I'll never make it again I never did but
no I mean there are tons of men I can't
I can do I mean I have a whole list of
mistakes that were made you know
everything from you know pages of a
speech being left out of the binder to
tell upon prompter operators like
falling asleep during the middle of a
speech
the teleprompter glass breaking - no
rain sites for events we had this awful
day and that was terrible they like
canceled the World Series the same day
and we had an event outside it was
pouring rain I mean like teeming and he
wakes up that morning and he goes so
Reggie what's the rain sighs I'm like
well you know there were no Syme trying
to explain it to him this elegant way in
which like there's no rain sight but we
have a really good reason as to why
there's no rain sight and whatever that
reason we thought was was not good
enough for him
and so he doesn't eat breakfast he
doesn't put on a suit he doesn't pack
his bag we get in the car we drive
straight to the event site because
people are outside waiting and they're
waiting in the rain and it's cold it's
freezing it's like a week before
Election Day really cold and he's like
you know people are gonna be sick with
like pneumonia they won't be able to go
vote
so it's pouring down rain it's freezing
cold he addresses the crowd you can't
like you can't even see keep in mind
you're not allowed to have an umbrella
because Secret Service no umbrellas no
umbrellas right now is pouring rain and
there's no protection yeah and he chose
to go out without an umbrella to I think
in solidarity he went out without an
umbrella and enduring the remarks I I
walk in to the polgr whole rooms like
nice and warm and dry and I kind of say
to guys I'm like look man when he gets
off the stage man you guys know you guys
don't want to look dry he's changed
since you know you know him as a senator
and knowing him as president how much I
mean I think you know I mean they're
there obviously obviously the physical
differences and I think you know I think
the job takes a toll on you and I think
to that
the job takes a toll mainly because you
know when things like kind of get to his
desk they're kind of like you know the
options are like bad and worse right and
so I don't think as a person I don't
think like I think its sense of humors
still the same I think the way it
interacts with people still the same I
think I think he's definitely grown in a
lot to being president and like you know
I think he's always had an immense
amount of respect for the office but I
do think that you know there is
definitely growth because you're doing a
lot of things for the first time you
know like how many you know rival
ceremonies have you been to when you are
a junior senator from Illinois how many
you know multi-country negotiations have
you like I think you definitely grow and
learn and evolve and I think he has but
I don't think and I don't think it had
its core and all these change hi Reggie
thank you so much for coming to share
with us my name is Amanda I'm a joint
degree student between the business
school in the Kennedy School so one I
think it's so fantastic to have the
president's humanized in a way that I
think is sometimes very difficult when
we think about the presidency as a high
office I'm curious how the president
processes really difficult issues and he
has to take a stance on what comes most
immediately to mind is what's happening
in Baltimore now where the president has
to represent all of America but is a
black man in America today
how does he process what he has to say
at times like this and balance those
things I mean I think that's a very well
I'll break that into two and Amanda
that's a great question as well what are
you focusing on in your MBA so general
MBA here need you yes but I'm from Kenya
so I'm real interested in developing you
from Kenya Nairobi oh you remember the
president right when he when he went as
a candidate I didn't know
one day Michelle when they got her
question though I think two parts of it
I think one as a whole and I mean he
deals with a lot of tough decisions all
the time and then there's like this
whole other thing which is Baltimore and
race in the country and I think for you
know very tough decisions I think he
does a very good job of taking in a lot
of data and a lot of points of views you
know he will listen to everyone's point
of view on an issue regardless if it's
contradictory to his or not and I think
that that's very different from some
leadership styles I think some people
who have very tough decisions want to
hear all the supporting reasons why the
thing that they're going to decide is
like the right decision but I think he
does a very good job of saying hey well
you know what are the counterpoint to
this and you know how how hard can it be
broken down and is there a middle ground
and sometimes you know he's even he
already has his mind already made up but
he still has the wherewithal to listen I
remember a day when they were trying to
take a decision on the auto bailout and
he asked like a junior staffer in the
room was probably like 27 at the time
say what do you think and the guy was
like it was Brian Deese very was 31
running the auto bailout yeah and so you
know and I think he just does a really
good job of bringing in a lot of
different perspectives in terms of
Baltimore as a whole I think his
comments or have been have been spot-on
I think his perspective and his message
probably is tailored a little more from
his own personal experience as you know
he's he is a black man who grew up here
in the United States and I think he
probably he has a little more sort of
personal sort of experience alongside of
it more than you know probably a lot of
the other people who are senior advisors
in its and the administration but I
think look
it's a difficult time where we are today
but I think he also believes that you
know we've come a very long way
technology today affords us the ability
to for people in Boston to feel like
they know what's going on like on the
grounds in Baltimore right like and not
like three or four days later like
instantaneously and and I think that
these you know incidences are a good
opportunity for us to grow as a country
and I think you know he's done a lot of
you know interesting things around
looking at the different processes and
how police officers are engaging with
with potential suspects the training
that they go through all the different
protocols that they're taking I think
he's just done they've done a really
good job sort of analyzing it they've
had the opportunity because of Ferguson
because of what happened in New York
City there Garner because of Trayvon
Martin high and even though those are
hard things to to swallow and to see I
think you know he's been out in front
sort of trying to figure out how can we
make things a little bit a little bit
better now granted like trying to make
things better for tomorrow does not
necessarily help us feel better about
where we are today yep I'm John Clark
Levin I'm a second year master and
public policy student here at the
Kennedy School I'm wondering some
presidents have been very guarded even
with their intimate staff members while
others let their hair down more FDR was
famously very reserved even around
people he was close with whereas Lyndon
Johnson infamously met with people while
he was in the bathroom so I'm wondering
from your experience of President Obama
what
the ways in which he could let his hair
down around you and other clothes staff
members and what were the ways maybe he
was private and guarded even around you
well I definitely I'm definitely pretty
certain he didn't have any bathroom
meetings what I think I saw that on
episode of house of cards though too
which is really cool I think how is he
sort of how does he interact on a
personal level with with the staff I
think you know he has like a pretty good
sense for you know cuz his daughters are
relatively young so he has a pretty good
sense of like pop culture and
entertainment and he watches and reads
like everything so you know he'll have a
conversation about you know what he
thought you know the last episode of Mad
Men really mentor he'll talk about you
know sports with you know with Dennis
McDonagh or he'll talk about you know
whatever is out there I mean he loves I
mean he he consumes like so much stuff
that I'm always surprised I remember
like one day I got an email from him and
like 1 o'clock in the morning and he
said like in the White House in the
White House in the White House is he's
president the United States and you were
there too were you and I'm working there
okay and he said you know what's up but
he's very life guys like and the Buried
life for these guys on MTV who were
going around trying to they had like a
bucket list of all the things they
wanted to do and I don't know like he's
I guess who's watching the Buried Life
at like what whatever time and he sends
his email and I said to him look you
know your team decided that it wasn't
work do you like meeting with them or
bringing the body goes let's bring him
by anyway I don't care it's like I'm
president I want to bring him by so so
he emails me this this is like a
middle-of-the-night
exchange of and so you know so that's
like a small example
and I can remember in which you know and
I don't know if you guys even remember
this show or not but like he's just you
know he he consumes a lot and he's he's
very you know engaged with people around
you know issues that are not just about
policy media entertainment sports
lattice points a lot of sports thank you
hey Reggie thank you very much for
coming my name is Russell I'm a first
year law student and a former body man
for a member of Congress so PTSD you
never get over it
yeah so in light of that I'm wondering
you had a lot of experience and a lot of
time with incredible men and women
whether it's you know Pete Roush or the
president obviously and all these people
that you can really soak up a lot from
but I'm wondering how you were able to
or potentially failed to toe the line
between sort of professionalism and you
know seeking out these individuals as
whether it was a mentor or sometimes you
know the president referred to us like a
little brother so I'm curious you know
how you went about making sure you
didn't cross over that and ask an
inappropriate question in an appropriate
time or but at the same time still you
know soaked up as much as you possibly
could in your time you know I think and
I honestly think that I don't think
there are any inappropriate questions if
they're phrase properly I remember back
in 2008 it's like like August and this
was like pre tarp and he's like on the
phone with Bush like every day and he's
like they're trying to figure out what
they're gonna do about you know these
banks and he was like working it's like
a bipartisan effort working to figure
this out and like we're in the middle of
the campaign I'm thanking myself and I
say you know serve like like I'm just
like confused a bit because like in
theory if things get really really bad
right now
like it would probably make it a lot
easier for you to get elected in
November and he goes no that's no that's
probably like a very fair assessment and
this is so this question is basically
going like this is like a question it's
like so why are you spending so much
time talking to like President Bush and
he answers the question he says look you
know like the people who are gonna be
the most affected by this they're gonna
be not the people who work in the banks
was gonna be the small businesses they
don't wanna have access to credit that
can't make payroll they can't you know
go out and you know procure whatever
supplies and equipment they need in
order to provide their services to to
ultimately like put food on the table of
middle-class citizens so I so I think in
a form of a question I think that's
totally fair I think there are other
scenarios that I definitely have I
probably did not do that great of a job
towing a lot but it has less to do with
sort of the mentoring aspect and more to
do with you know like when you are
playing golf or basketball or you're
competing with somebody like you know
when are you like competing against like
someone that you're in competition with
and when are they your boss and I think
that's like a very hard thing to to get
right sometimes and I've definitely you
know I have like had to apologize in
like and I didn't mean to yell at you
about that call but like I was really
like heated at the time and I do think
that and my biggest point around this
sue is that there's like no coach cage
to say this all the time they're like no
such thing as stupid questions they're
just like stupid people who don't ask
questions and it's easy especially like
you guys are like all like probably
really smart and experts at whatever it
is you're studying and teaching and
professing and you know the hard thing
to do I think is to let someone else
know that like you don't know everything
that you you know what like you would
like more information about something
that you know what I probably could go
and do a little
research on this because I'm not really
up to speed on it and I think that
that's like where you like have like the
most amount of growth in places where
you either don't agree with people and
you are asking tough and challenging
questions and you're having those those
dialogues or places where you know
you're having conversations where you're
uncomfortable because you're you're not
necessarily the most educated person on
the topic and I think you can just I
mean I I think that was for me probably
the best part about most of my
experiences is that you know I felt
uncomfortable all the time because I was
like typically like the least smartest
person in most of the meetings my name
is Elia I'm an undergraduate student at
Wellesley I was very lucky I got to work
at the office for public engagement at
the White House during the fall and how
far as Wellesley from here and I saw the
great things that were coming out of the
administration like my brother's keeper
and the council for women and girls and
all of these really wonderful
initiatives and every day I would you
know very religious really read
political it's a very DC thing to do and
no one was talking about the good work
how does the president deal with the
polarization of the media the fact that
people go to the media sources that
confirm their views not the ones that
challenge them how does he deal with the
fact that in today's world the White
House press briefing room is really
really not that relevant well the reason
why people are spending like multi
billion dollars on campaigns so that
they can like basically have their own
media outlet and I also think that - I
think he understands that look at its
you know people with people it's
competitive like the the the news
landscape is more competitive today
it has ever been and so look there is
some times there that you find yourself
when the things that are like really
driving click-throughs and subscriptions
and viewership are not the warm fuzzy
success stories and I think that you
know I think he gets it I think I mean
how you people involved if all they hear
is the bad stuff if all they hear is the
fighting and not the hope well I think I
think that I think that is part of the
story that is a part of the story about
being involved you know when you see
that there is this much gridlock and
fighting and sort of stagnation it means
that like more people need to be
involved in the process and more people
need to become you know educated and
engaged and having their own dialogues
and their own communities about these
issues I mean because ultimately you
know none of these issues are like won
or lost on CNN I mean they were won and
lost in like living rooms and in
churches and in town hall meetings and
in places like here this is like where
this is where it happens right now I
think the media tries to you know they
try to come up with storylines to help
sort of move people in a certain
direction but you know it's really up to
us to dig down deep and to look very
analytically at what's going on and what
are the things that are important to us
and what are the things that are gonna
make a difference so it's not just look
at the things that are being fed to us
and you know I think that's hard you
know it's a very hard thing to do we
have short attention spans and you know
there's a lot of things that are
competing for our time and our attention
I'm sure everyone's got three devices
and
you know you got your friends and
girlfriend or wife and kids it's just
it's it's a it's a hard thing it's a
hard thing to do but I think when you
when you get to the core of it when you
get down to sort of the basic needs a
necessity which are you know people want
a chance to be they want a chance to you
know get a good education have an
employment have secured long-term
security financially in in with
healthcare and you know they won't have
the chance to live the American dream
that people feel like they have that
opportunity
they'll be engaged and involved you know
for years to come but the moment you
know people feel like that thing is no
longer attainable then you know people
become more and more disenchanted and
and I think those that's also the moment
when people have to sort of turn in and
and dig a little deeper and and work a
little harder to help get us back on
course so last question you've seemed up
close and personal what it's like to be
president would you ever run not an
advertisement for it look man you saying
you've seen up close would you run I
enjoy the view that I have anyway thank
you so much Reggie I'm sorry okay my
name is Malik Jo booty I'm actually a
high school senior so what do you think
has been Barack Obama's biggest
accomplishment as president I think what
will ultimately be and I think health
care will be that will be then will be
looked at like the New Deal
I think ACA will be the most historic
thing that has happened to our country
in a while I know a lot of people argue
otherwise and I can sure I can find a
hundred website to say the opposite but
me personally and I think hands down I
don't even think there's yeah I mean
it'll it's the most important thing
that's happened in the last
well thank you so much Reggie love for
coming to power forward my presidential
education if only to read the part about
when he catches Reggie with a girl